dans le village l'église et ses coupoles
bleus sont intactes mais il n'y a plus
qu el
béchir est sur la route de kiev pour les
russes alors ils l'ont bombardé cette
jeune fille et l
allemagne s ma cousine et ma grand mère
dormait dans cette pièce elles vont bien
mais tout leur est tombée dessus c'est
une bombe qui a soufflé l'intérieur de
la maison là à quelques mètres et voici
son cratère
lorsqu'on ne la profondeur ou à
descendre c'est le centre communal et la
mairie qui a été visé la bombe à creuser
ce trou immense
sur la route de la percée russe il y à
des villages où parfois la vie se
poursuit comme avant nous suivons sur
des cartes en temps réel l'armée de
vladimir poutine rouge l'a avancé des
russes qui élève est à 30 km à peine et
sans doute moins à vol d'oiseau des
champs de mines les derniers barrages
jusque là il était tenu par des
villageois en armes de moins en moins
nombreux et finalement nous sommes
stoppés par ces militaires très bien
équipé
il ne faut pas passer ce barrage de
l'autre côté c'est dangereux il faut pas
y aller
la patrouille elle s'avance en fait elle
va récupérer un drone pour espionner les
russes
on nous demande de nous mettre à l'abri
mais les tirs sourds d'artillerie
il faut évacuer
on est clairement d'aller au centre en
urgence
c'était en fait le dernier barrage
la ligne de front nous roulons dans
l'autre sens
la patrouille s'arrête ces soldats en
fait un filtre les lignes russes
c'est quoi votre mission
on va derrière leur ligne on les attaque
on en tue plus possible que
ont détruit leur artillerie l'infanterie
tout ce qu'on peut trouver
une colonne de civils fuient les combats
mais on a vu les temps qu'on les a vus
il fuit et ont fabriqué à la va-vite ces
drapeaux blancs avec des torchons et des
manches auxquelles nous ont expliqué ces
militaires avec une femme restait donc à
peu près une heure c'est que les russes
se divisent maintenant en petit groupe
et qu'il se cache dans ses bois là tout
autour pour avancer de poste en poste et
se diriger vers kiev